peut-on avoir le mot confiance et
technologie dans la même phrase
si ça vous semble un peu étrange je
comprends mais c'est aujourd'hui
pleinement possible grâce à ce qu'on
appelle la bloc chaîne
reviens en arrière
voici trois époques trois types de
réseaux et trois économie
la première époque celle des médias
Télécom dans les années 80 à 2000 était
extrêmement centralisée il y avait un
émetteur et plein de petits récepteurs
autour
le pouvoir décisionnel aussi était
centralisé il y avait pas que le moyen
de communication
ensuite nous avons eu l'air des
plateformes à partir des années 2000
on a évolué vers un modèle un peu plus
décentralisé
mais le pouvoir est la valeur remonter
toujours vers le point central le
créateur
ensuite nous sommes allés vers un
nouveau modèle
si vous regardez bien la différence
entre le troisième et les deux premiers
schéma il n'y a aucun point central de
contrôle dans le 3e
tous les points bleus sont
interconnectés entre eux
et ça c'est un réseau distribué ou toute
la valeur est répartie entre les membres
du réseau c'est fondamentalement nouveau
et ça
c'est une blague chaîne
alors comment ça fonctionne et
bien ce sont des centaines de milliers
d'ordinateurs répartit partout sur la
planète comme ce que vous voulez voir
avec les petits points bleus
les données sont agrégées sous forme de
bloc ça veut dire que on rentre des
données dans un premier bloc et quand il
est plein on va passer au bloc suivant
et ainsi de suite mais du coup de génie
vient maintenant
c'est en fait je l'ai bloque son corps
et les mathématiques man ils ont tous
une maison mathématiques les entre
donc ça veut dire que tous les blocs ont
des données logiques qui se suivent si
dans notre exemple nous en avions le
bloc numéro 2 le bloc 1 et 3 n'aurai
plus de coïncidence logique il y aurait
donc tout simplement une rupture entre
les deux strictement impossible sur une
blague chaîne car les données sont
toutes Chesnaie de bouton bout du début
à la fin tout ce qui est entré est gravé
dans le marbre numérique
d'autre part ce qui fait aussi un réseau
blockchaine c'est son code
un code que l'on appelle Open Source un
code Open Source c'est comme une
partition de musique
vous avez des notes vous allez les
jouets vous n'allez pas inventer des
notes que vous n'avez pas sur votre
partition on allait pas en enlever non
plus tout le monde l'entendrait vous
allez simplement jouer ce qui est écrit
ni plus ni moins un code ouvert Open
Source c'est exactement la même chose
tout le monde peut le lire l'audit et le
regarder et quand il y a écrit
l'instruction est exécutera un moment si
jamais il n'y a rien écrit il y aura
aucune exécution il n'y a pas de
fonctions cachées qui pourrait sortir
comme ça c'est pour ta Léman c'est
impossible tout est clair et limpide dès
le départ
on va dire très bien mais où se trouve
la confiance et bien la confiance elle
est dans cet ensemble dans ces trois
piliers distant la confiance elle est
dans un réseau distribué. Tu as. Sans
intermédiaire elle se trouve également
dans une chaîne de blocs où les données
sont toutes agences et les yeux d'un
côté les autres et une suite logique
elle se trouve également dans le code
et avec ça on a un ensemble cohérent qui
fait que la bloque chaîne c'est la
technologie de la preuve tout ce que
vous entrez est une preuve il peut vous
servir tout au long de votre vie
alors j'aimerais vous présenter trois
exemples concrets qui font que l'on peut
se servir des services de la chaîne au
quotidien le premier exemple auquel je
pense et celui de Bitcoin
vous en avez probablement tous entendu
parler
il s'agit d'un réseau de paiement de
paires impaires sans passer par un
organe central de contrôle sans
intermédiaire il permet d'envoyer de la
monnaie dans le monde entier en quelques
minutes que vous soyez à côté ou à 20 km
de distance c'est la même chose
mais il a une petite particularité il a
été créée en 2008 après la crise
financière
mais son auteur est en inconnu total je
ne faisant pas on ne sait toujours pas
qui c'est aujourd'hui et on dit souvent
mais Jérôme comment tu peux avoir
confiance dans ce truc on connaît même
pas l'auteur
peut-on avoir confiance en quelqu'un
qu'on ne connaît pas
et bien permettez-moi de vous donner un
contre-exemple et vous le connaissez
tous
Facebook
tout le monde connaît son patron tout le
monde sait qu'il est il est sur les
chaînes de télé par tu connais tout son
visage mais tout ce qu'il fait est
purement discrétionnaire il fait les
choses de son côté il ordonne certaines
choses à faire équipe et on en a
absolument aucune idée
les algorithmes de Facebook sont
complètement fermé on en connaît
éventuellement les conséquences mais on
ne sais même pas comment c'est fait à
l'intérieur c'est une opacité totale
à l'inverse avec des collines certes on
ne connaît pas son créateur on ne sait
pas quel âge il a combien de frères et
soeur il a vu mais est-ce vraiment
important parce que la preuve c'est ce
qu'il y a écrit dans le code c'est le
réseau c'est la structure et la
confiance elle vient de là elle vient de
se réseau qui depuis 2008 exécuter
exactement ce que je me demande sans
avoir failli une seule fois mais quand
il n'est jamais tombé en panne jamais
depuis 2008 ça fonctionne exactement
comme il était prévu
alors la confiance elle se trouve
là-dedans dans des protocoles ouverts
distribuer dans un code ou vers libre
que tout le monde petit pot et il vous
suffit de Somme connexion internet
le deuxième exemple donc je voudrais
vous parler
tu appelles la vie failli la finance
décentralisée
il s'agit d'une alternative à la finance
traditionnelle avec beaucoup plus
d'atouts
la fille non décentralisée ça permet à
n'importe qui dans le monde avec une
simple connexion internet d'accéder à
votre service financier auquel certaines
populations n'avez pas accès au
Parlement il y a un, 8 milliards de
personnes dans le monde qui sont non
bancariser est-ce qu'on doit les
laissés-pour-compte non pas du tout avec
une simple connexion internet il est
possible que tu as des services
financiers
des prés des empreintes les assurances
et souscription d'actions de
l'immobilier
et ça fonctionne tu manière extrêmement
simple et sécurisé pour les prêts vous
pouvez prêter de l'argent et la somme
que vous prêter vous allez forcément
toucher des intérêts dessus mais
contrairement non traditionnels les
intérêts vont les touchez pas à la fin
de l'année
oui toucher en temps réel tous les 24
heures
si vous emprunter de l'argent vous aller
déposer un actif numérique un collatéral
bloqué il va être figé dans la chaîne et
on va pouvoir vous permettre d'obtenir
le ligne de crédit instantanément il n'y
a pas d'analyse de dossier il n'y a pas
de temps d'attente on avait pas attendre
que le conseiller vous dit si oui ou non
il veut bien vous accorder un prêt chez
media
dans le domaine des assurances vous
pouvez souscrire une assurance en cas de
retard d'un avion par exemple
et ça se fait tu m'as l'air tellement
simple que tout le reste devient presque
ringard quand vous souscrivez une
assurance
si l'avion arrive en retard vous êtes
automatiquement rembourser sur votre
carte bleue en euros avant même que vous
soyez sorti de l'appareil
vous n'avez aucun papier envoyer aucun
coup de fil à passer pas de temps à
perdre tout se fait automatiquement
quand j'avais quand vous avez goûté à ça
une fois plus envie de revenir en
arrière
vous pouvez aussi acheter des actions
par exemple et comme sur la chaîne tout
est divisible vous pouvez acheter des
fractions d'action
même si elles sont très onéreuse vous
pouvez acheter tout à partir dans leur
ou dans l'immobilier c'est pareil vous
pouvez acheter des actifs qui
représentent des actifs immobilier dans
le monde entier c'est comme une super
SCPI à l'échelle mondiale et là aussi
c'est accessible à partir d'un euro
l'avantage c'est qu'avec technologie on
abaisse la barrière à l'entrée sur une
norme aimant de nouveau marché et on
touche des populations beaucoup plus
large c'est beaucoup plus équitable
la confiance elle se trouve dans ces
protocoles qui sont interopérable avec
des tout qui sont variables qui sont mis
à jour automatiquement manière
transparente sur l'offre et la demande
ça se passe entre les utilisateurs
depuis le départ tout est transparent et
vous avancez si vous le souhaitez
le 3e exemple donc je voudrais vous
parler concerne les aime les femmes
token n'ayez pas peur ce terme en parler
peut-être un peu barbare mais ce n'est
absolument pas
un token c'est un actif numérique sur la
blockchain ça peut être une photo un son
une vidéo ce que vous souhaitez ce qui
est fongible et ce qu'est échangeable
interchangeable si on prend deux plus de
champagne que l'on achète elles sont
totalement interchangeables mais si un
artiste me dédicace je n'ai plus de
champagne elle devient unique elle est
donc non fongible
et bien un token dans son Gilles c'est
un token qu'un des propriétés unique et
je vous montre un exemple ici avec l'
artiste français Pascal Boyard il a
peint des fresques dans toute la France
est gigantesque certaines ont même été
effacés
maison en double numérique qui vit sur
la bloque chaîne et qui subsiste
et dans notre cas l'artiste a voulu
divisé en son token identiques sa
fresque
et au calme tous un petit peu différent
sur un point c'est que si vous achetez
le numéro 52 vous n'avez pas la même
partie que le numéro 25 et vous pouvez
acheter une fresque dans son ensemble ou
vous pouvez l'acheter en petite fraction
tout est fractionnable n'importe quel
active devient fractionnable connecter
ce sont les marchés de la rareté
numérique on peut collectionner les
œuvre les cartes les cartes à jouer des
articles dans un jeu vidéo sur son
nouveau monde qui s'ouvre à nous et la
confiance là encore elle est entre
l'artiste et sa communauté directement
on appelle ça la Creative économie
mais ce qui est le plus beau là-dedans
avec les left et ce n'est pas forcément
que ça
ce qui est intéressant c'est de regarder
le dessous des cartes
pourquoi les élèves qui sont très
important parce que pour la première
fois les artistes pour la garantie par
le code qu'ils vont être retribue
instantanément à chaque revente vous
avez bien entendu pour la première fois
à chaque fois qu'un actif numérique va
changer demain
l'artiste va percevoir une rémunération
immédiate c'est lui qui va la fixer en
créant son anniv te il va tu as prévu
une rémunération qui peut varier par
exemple de 5 à 15 % et à chaque fois que
je l'active changera demain chaque fois
que tu auras un nouveau propriétaire
la personne sera rémunéré
l'artiste ne dépend plus d'autre il
interagit directement avec sa communauté
de père à faire et la confiance encore
une fois et là dedans dans ses
protocoles qui garantissent pour le
client l'authenticité de l' œuvre de
l'artiste et qui garantit la l'artiste
une rémunération juste et équitable
j'aimerais vous dire que c'est tout ce
que je vous dis vous surprend c'est
peut-être un peu normal c'est très
nouveau
en revanche on a tous vu l'air internet
et puis finalement on s'adapte et peu à
peu la technologie évolue
mets l'air du plateforme a montré
sérieusement ses limites les limites
justement dans lesquelles on se poser
des question de confiance vis-à-vis des
données qui était agrégé vis-à-vis de la
captation de pouvoir de certaines
plateformes
ta toute-puissance pousse quand même de
sérieux problèmes
aujourd'hui ce que je trouve très
intéressant c'est qu'avec la bloc chaîne
pour la première fois nous avons une
technologie qui permet des femmes
naissance dans le code d'intégrer la
confiance dès le départ
on dit en anglais c'est fait by design
ça veut dire des la conception et si
nous arrivons à intégrer la conception
de la confiance dès le départ que
peut-on faire
se consacrer sur l'essentiel et
l'essentiel c'est l'humain
la confiance est déjà là une grande
partie du travail est fait il nous reste
à nous concentrer sur les mains
vous savez la technologie c'est toujours
un moyen ça n'est jamais jamais une fin
elle évolue dans le temps toujours
et l'avantage c'est que si nous faisons
des choix sérieux des choix éthiques
nous serons toujours présent pour
pouvoir en tirer le meilleur parti je
vous remercie